Hello, record fans. My name is Lucky Diamond Rich...
...and I am the current Guinness World Record holder for the most tattooed person in the world.
Well, I started getting tattooed because basically, I was traveling with a circus...
...and yeah, it was just one of those things. It was an underground art form...
...and it was a way of being able to collect art.
Because I was an artist already, I decided that that would be a good thing to do.
And yeah, I just got a few tattoos here and there and like postcards from different areas.
And then it just went from there and obviously because I kept traveling...
...and doing that, it just kinda ended up being one, big, massive postcard.
I started experimenting with black tattooing, solid black tattooing...
...and the idea of going over the black with different patterns in white or color.
And yeah, that was pretty successful so yeah, I did that and it ended up being a good idea.
And it worked out good, so I just went, "That's it. That's what I'm gonna do."
"I'm gonna cover everything that I've got."
My first layer and then these solid black,...
...and then go over that with white, and then go over that with color.
So, it's just a way to either push the tattoo art form forward...
...and to do something that no one else had done.
And also, on the way, snatch the world record.